Kit Harington got married not that long
ago nearly a year ago yeah about a year
ago and and you were invited to the
bachelor party
I was that must have been oh I'm just
assuming it's Kit Harington one of the
most famous faces on the globe getting
married was that a crazy bachelor party
[Laughter]
well I'll let you be the judge of that
when I tell you that we went go-karting
you went go-kart even go Kyle
okay next question go karting really
won't go as part of it um yeah but the
thing about me and go karting is one I'm
a super cautious driver like
pathologically cautious right and two I
don't really have that competitive
spirit somebody says to me somebody
challenge me I bet I could beat you at
tennis
I'm like yeah probably yeah probably can
and so I was never gonna really get on
with it but I didn't cover myself in
glory at all
so did you did you actually have a race
I mean who did well at this they had a
race yeah I didn't have what you
technically call a race I got there you
put you put like an all-in-one race suit
on velcro's at the front yeah i sat in
the car Bosh just the whole just the
whole front of the velcro burst I wasn't
up to the job
I'm afraid I'm they would let me open my
shirt open
they put a helmet on me so on my face
with all kind of squash right but my
face is so soft and flabby that the kind
of pressure of the helmet with closing
my eyes I thought I'm in trouble so we
so we all took off from there yeah from
the pit and they shot off they shot off
so quick and as soon as I sat in the car
the cart was like this like I can't take
this guy around this track so they they
shot off and because I was basically way
in the car down the car kind of started
like this
and then took off so they were going
round it like however a considerable
number of my thirty miles an hour miles
an hour
and I was just essentially driving round
very slowly slowly shivering having a
Sunday Drive around the bend and then
whenever they pass me they'd stay
screech passed me on corners never liked
me you maniacs
[Laughter]
just just [ __ ] slowing down just to
almost to stop before you just turn
corners very slowly and then they all
finished and by the time they finished
each lap was three each race with three
laps
I had a lap and a half to go by the time
everybody was finished so I thought so I
was just driving on it a lap and a half
to go I could see them in the distance
at like the clubhouse is going we'd have
to stand there surely and watch this guy
drive around a lap and a half really
slow this is a bachelor party this is
why I signed up for but luckily I say
luckily it was humiliating
the guy from the from the go-kart plays
drove a little quad bike out drove a
little quad bike out round the track and
his back and being really gentle big
coned half the track off so I didn't
have to do the full race and I was
really sheepish they just pulled in like
this and the worst thing about it all
was the was the round of applause from
the group yeah yeah I was five years old
yeah so wild no embarrassing most
definitely